God has a calling for each and every
single one of us God gave me a certain
type of genetics bodybuilding it's all
about
[Music]
Ronnie Coleman is arguably the best
bodybuilder of all time having won the
Mr Olympia title for eight consecutive
years even though his bodybuilding
championships are behind him he's making
more money now than he ever has in the
past from his multi-million dollar
income bodybuilding businesses and full
rags to Rich's story that's definitely
going to inspire you to hit the gym make
some money and also subscribe but first
a quick thank you to our sponsor
netsuite Ronnie Coleman has an amazing
business although the start of every
amazing business comes with a strong
foundation and a strong Foundation does
not include complicated spreadsheets and
countless different softwares if you
want to help restructure your business
but you don't know where to start just
remember these three numbers from our
sponsor netsuite that would be thirty
six thousand twenty five and one thirty
six thousand because over 36 000
companies have already upgraded to
netsuite and stopped wasting time on
things like manual data entry and
sifting through scattered data 25
because netsuite has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their
costs and one because netsuite is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage all of your kpis your key
performance indicators with one
efficient system netsuite will help
prevent all the busy work that comes
with scaling up your business and even
if you're not looking to scale netsuite
helps you cut down on mistakes with
manual data entry so get a full picture
of your business and start making better
decisions faster and right now you could
download netsuite's popular kpis
checklist for free at netsuite.com iced
again that's netsuite.com ice to get a
free checklist on popular kpis
netsuite.com iced and again it's free
you may as well do it because it costs
you nothing so enjoy thank you so much
and now let's get back to the episode
thank you so much ah no problem it's an
honor it really really an honor watching
your videos when I was just getting into
the gym was so inspirational for me I
think it was really you and Jay Cutler
for me it was just like watching you
guys lift the dedication was insane it
just it got me hyped up to go to the gym
it was inspiration for me to want to
work out well me and Jacob had some
pretty good battles over the years so
David one of the reasons why I was so
hyped up in the gym a lot of times
really so I could imagine where you
probably could have done for some other
people if you did that for me I can't
believe it I'm sure you've said this a
million times but just for people who
aren't familiar with you in your story
at what age did you get into
bodybuilding the bodybuilding itself I
think I was like 26.
and I started working out when I was 12
though you know
as a kid uh growing up in a small town
everywhere I went people always ask me
if I worked out
when I was about 10 years old
and this went on for a very long time a
time I got like 12 I'm like man I wonder
what I look like if I really started
working out at 12 yeah this was after
everywhere I went people asked me you
work out you can't be did you work out
you kind of big
[Music]
what about like height wise I looked
like I worked out all the time no I'll
just say that really is that just
illuminatics yeah exactly it's pure
genetics yeah I get it from my mom for
the most part she was pretty muscular
too her whole entire life so at the age
of 12 I mean after hearing all this do
my workout for so long I'm like man
wanna what I look like if I actually
started working out and I got tired of
saying no
so I just started working out when I got
you know 12 years old and I kind of fell
in love with it when I got to like
almost 13
and uh when I was 13 some of the guys in
high school said man you pretty big guy
you you're coming to high school we
don't want you to be on our power
lifting team like oh man I can't wait
till I get to the high school so I can
get on this without this team so I can
really you know you know find out how to
really work out because I didn't really
know too much about at the time I was
doing you know when I started you know I
didn't look at no magazines in there I
just did you know what I thought you
should be doing you know for to build
muscle which wasn't too much nothing but
more no more than what probably like
curls and overhead uh presses and stuff
like that but once I got to the uh High
School
and uh learn how to do power lifting
that's when I really fell in love with
working out big time at 12 though where
did you go to work out was it like at a
gym or is it like a we had a little gym
at uh at the school
it wasn't much it's just you know a few
dumbbells your balls it wasn't like you
know we had these machines yeah it was
just a few dumbbells and a few bars and
that was it it wasn't nothing actually I
had probably more than what they had at
school when I went out and bought this
pound uh concrete weight set from
Walmart I had more weights when I bought
that from Walmart than we had at school
I didn't even realize they had concrete
Nails in the backyard me and my friends
you know we used to work out just about
every day we'd be back there squatting
doing curls and stuff like that this was
like when I was like 13 you know how did
you learn to enjoy working out because
for me I've been working out now I would
say inconsistently for like three years
consistently for about a year and still
even today I have kind of a love-hate
relationship with it a lot of the times
I really don't want to work out I don't
want to go to the gym I feel exhausted
sometimes I really enjoy it but how do
you learn to enjoy it at 12 years old
where I feel like most people just want
to go out hang out with their friends
play kickball and have fun I don't think
it's too much really about enjoying it
it was more I was uh Curious how I was
how I would look if I started working
out it was more of that but you know as
I got into it and learned more
I started falling in love with it
especially when I got to high school and
got on the power listing team and
started doing contests and stuff I
really you know everybody got there
thing that you know
we'll put on this Earth fall
and I I believe you know God gave me a
certain type of genetics to uh display
on a level that wasn't meant to be
uh unseen by the masses for the most
part it was like a hobby for me for the
most part and that initial spark of love
you would say came from powerlifting and
competing yeah learning how to work out
properly working properly yeah working
out properly and how to
you know get stronger you know because
you know the cute the older you are the
more stronger you want to be
so I learned about a lot how to become
stronger and how to you know become
bigger and stuff like that yeah
curiosity than anything was there ever a
competitive element in the beginning for
you of just like I want to be stronger
than that guy or was it more for
yourself if like if I could lift myself
you know outlifted a month ago then
that's a win no I would say it was more
of a competitive thing because since you
know I was competing once I got to high
school I was competing against other you
know
schools for the most part I don't really
know who owns in those meets because
some of those guys look pretty old to me
you know they were like like
like the local meet in that town I don't
think they said only High School people
can join and you have to be a certain
age I don't think they did it off that
they just said whoever showed up
and wanted to compete could compete
because uh some of those guys were
pretty big and real strong now back then
what did you think you wanted to do for
a living like man I wanted to play
football for a minute because I played
football in junior high
high school college and uh I remember
talking to some of the scouts from the
pros and they would come to the school I
was at all the time and you know the
guys that were
they looked you know that played real
well
the guys that they let uh dudes trials
with the scouts and now you know I was
one of those guys that you know did the
tryouts and everything
and I was supposed to at least I thought
I was going to get drafted at the end of
the year at least but the guy was
telling me one of the scouts was telling
me you're looking at me to get drafted
but
when that didn't happen
of course you know since I had a degree
and I did pretty good in school I
figured I'd just uh go down another path
why don't you think he got packed why
don't I think
to be honest with you after I
look at it and I I see that uh
God had a another path for me to go down
try at this certain path that he wanted
me to go down you know
we're not uh
asked to be here
uh none of us actually be here we all
put here
and God has a calling pretty much for at
least I think he does each and every
single one of us yeah most of us
have either a career or calling you know
we're gonna you know a career path that
we're going to go down a path of a
calling that we're going to go down
and uh for me I think the reason why I
didn't because in our pre-chosen you
know that
calling pass for me to go down because I
can still remember to this day
uh me going on a lot of those interviews
that I went on because I got I got my
degree in accounting and I graduated at
the top of my class I graduated
laude I just knew who I was gonna get a
job in accounting
I went on probably maybe 100 or so
interviews and got turned down by all of
them
I kind of knew then uh yeah so you're
just like this is after after a while I
knew at least it's like this is The
Universe telling me I this is not the
path to go exactly how do you shift from
that to then becoming a police officer
hold on I'm curious how did you get how
did you get turned down when you
graduated laude like I was saying
earlier just God's God God had a plan
for me to uh you know do something else
was there ever a reason why they tell
you that or like we're not gonna hire
you like too qualified your grades were
too good could it be that they see your
signature and just like maybe you don't
fit the mold of like what an account
like I imagine it kind of like a scrawny
kind of like
I don't know glasses and like yeah I
guess they knew too that you know God
God telling them they got something else
playing for you don't hire him I got a
random tangential question for those
that maybe haven't figured out God's
plan for them yet or their core or
direction that they should be going in
life the reason why they were put here
how do you recommend they go when they
find that or how do they know that the
right path that they're on right now is
the designated path for me it was pretty
easy whatever it is that you are so in
love with that you think is a hobby and
that you think you probably can't get
paid for
because it you have so much fun doing it
they said if you
if I have passion for something you
never really work a day in your life
if it's something like that that's
probably what you
've chosen uh you will put here to do
that's probably your calling or your
your career path that you know God is
chosen for you I completely agree with
that for me that's been both being a
real estate agent and YouTube I would
have worked for free and I did for quite
some time I just loved it it's all I
wanted to do in fact it makes money mine
was working for the police department
and uh doing bodybuilding yeah
I would I actually did work at police
department for free yeah when I you know
when I um
wanted Olympia my third time winning you
know I had to give it up man because I
was so busy uh going on so many trips
and doing so many appearances that I
didn't have time to really do police
work
and uh you can say I did bodybuilding
for free too because when I was amateur
and you don't get paid nothing yeah and
I was the amateur for a little while
there now how do you make the switch
from wanting to be in accounting to
police work yeah that was pretty easy
for me
well remember all those interviews that
went on and never got hired
there's only so so long you can have a
dream of getting hired by somebody and
to you you know just decide hey this
ain't gonna work I gotta find something
else that was uh you know that I'm I
think I might enjoy I still remember to
this day every time I got the newspaper
it was always time for a police officer
it was like no experience needed you
know most time
jobs they always like you gotta have
these two years experience five years
experience but the police job was always
no experience needed no I got to
thinking man that sounds like me back
then I ain't got no experience they got
these big old ads in the classified I'm
like I think that I had is calling me I
think I'm gonna answer that one don't
you have to go through Police Academy
yeah exactly and what was that like for
you how long it was three months okay it
was three months at the um it was a
college
called tcjc Tarrant County junior
college and then I had another three
months at uh the people that hired me
they had their own Academy
and uh after that that's when you hit
the streets it's only six months of
training to become a police officer yeah
did you need a bachelor's degree as well
no no you don't have to have a
bachelor's degree is it needed a high
school diploma but the department I had
hired on to that you had to have a
four-year degree if you didn't have a
four-year degree they wouldn't hire you
although before we go into that as I'm
sure you've seen our online information
is spreading everywhere and
unfortunately there are some data broker
websites out there that take your
information sell it and sometimes
nefarious people get a hold of it
clearly this sort of stuff is on the
rise and is a part of the younger
generation we know in an email or
website looks sketchy but what about our
parents their information gets gathered
and then sold on data broker websites
which then often go to scammers who
could create personalized messages to
try to scam them with delete me as a
software that hunts down your private
information that's exposed online and
eliminates it from those annoying data
broker websites plus delete me will
continue to remove your data every three
months helping Safeguard your privacy
year round and they even offer package
deals so you could protect your own
information while helping your parents
or even kids who are getting online at
an increasingly early age so take
control of your and your loved ones
personal information and regain Peace of
Mind through today's sponsor delete me
check out out join deleteme.com ich20 or
use promo code ich20 to get an exclusive
20 off all consumer plans again that's
code ich20 at joindeletme.com protect
yourself and stay private with delete me
and now with that said let's get back to
the episode I'm just curious uh how were
the physical challenges of like getting
to be a policeman did you have to go
through a physical examination or some
course or something like climb a wall or
maybe like bench a plate let me see yeah
I think they made us about a mile and a
half and we had the this obstacle course
we had to go through it was like three
walls one was like four foot high one
was like five foot high and the last one
was like seven foot high you had to yeah
and get over all three of those
and then go do some other stuff you know
like push up some sit-ups or something
and how was that for you was it just
like a walk in the park
like that's a normal workout for you
every morning
half back then in like five minutes you
know all right that wasn't nothing for
me now I hear you also have to be
tasered in pepper sprayed is that true
that's not true
you didn't get Peppers oh I haven't
shoot myself when I'm gone either no wow
yeah yeah I I I figured that those
things would work for me just by looking
at what they did to people wow so it
would volunteer it was kind of like a
volunteer thing because you wanted to
get pepper sprayed or taste that you
could
he said yeah
his volunteer and nope thank you after I
saw what it did to other people uh I
don't want I don't I don't I don't I
don't see that happen to me it's not
like that now I saw what they went
through do you remember what the pay was
like back then when you started working
as a police officer yeah it was pretty
good we made about
it was back in
88. I had on 89. we made about 45 000 a
year that's fantastic yeah so it was
almost like
an hour I know with part-time jobs we
made 20 now so it was pretty good money
and then you had the part-time job where
you can make like 20 an hour and it was
all cash at the end of the night really
I had three of the old jobs worked at
Denny's
I worked at a boot store uh
and then I worked at my apartment
complex what were you doing free rent uh
just tell them to turn the music down
really so you're one of the managers or
like one of the property on-site
property like an on-site security you
know I had to lock up the pools till
people get out you know
then uh and somebody complained about
loud music it would I always call you
and tell them go there and tell people
to turn the music down and stuff like
that and they listen to you right of
course they don't have a choice man they
knew what was good for them
how did you get that situation how did
you get free rent like that I always put
ads up at the police department saying
that you know we had we need a security
officer or something like that oh it's
smart no you know they had one person
that was over all that stuff and they
would go and get people to do that kind
of work yeah would you say you've always
been good with your money because it
seems like wanting to go into accounting
like yeah very numbers yeah I've always
been real good with my my money yeah
like I you know I I already have a
retirement in place that I collect
I think this year and next year and then
at 62 Social Security so that's like
three I heard you even worked at
Domino's because yeah
yeah that job came along because I
needed a job because I had a condo
coming up
back when I graduated uh College they
had this thing called a college degree
program at the dealerships they would
let anybody that had a college degree
come in and buy a car
the only thing was they would delay your
condo for three months
so I didn't have a job of course when I
went in and bought this car
and uh that third month was a coming up
and I'm like damn man got a job my car
note to do next month so I'm like I
gotta take the first thing came along
come along and Domino the piece was the
first thing coming along so I took that
job
so I wouldn't I could pay my car note
how much pizza did you eat though every
single day really every day as much as I
could was that did you find out that was
dinner was that good for working out I
know that was good for finance because I
kind of full of regular food you know
dinner to buy dinner that's how the who
I was back in the old days you know I
eat yeah pizza for dinner and then I got
tired of eating pizza after a while and
Kentucky Fried Chicken was next door to
me and I'm like I wanted they tired
chicken like I'm tired of eating pizza
let me call them and ask him yeah and
that's what I did and they like yeah you
want to trade you're like yeah so I
would trade them no Fried Chicken for
pizza then I got tired of eating fried
chicken well Burger King was next door
to them
so I just thought calling everybody just
trading food so it's still free
everything you were eating was smart
yeah free food free rent what was that
what was the car you bought it was a
Pontiac Sunbird okay 87. and how long
did you keep that car for I kept that
car for a four year oh wow and deliver
pizza in there and everything
were you not concerned about like the
macros of the pizza I didn't know what
that was no but you weren't you working
out very powerless I I had abs
all the time you know no matter what I
ate I was in pretty good condition no
matter what I ate and back in those days
I didn't know what diet was so I eat a
lot of fried chicken a lot of hamburgers
and a lot of pizza
and I was still in pretty good condition
so genexa um pretty good there and then
at what point did you start taking your
diet seriously when I started
bodybuilding and that was at age
26 yeah that's when I started taking it
serious yeah tell us a story about the
guy who told you to get into
bodybuilding I found that really
interesting yeah well
showed up on a call one day with another
officer and he's like man where you work
out at like dude I'm working at the
station where it's free
it's like oh man you ain't no wasting
that for you I'm like dude you're right
they really hated the most I put on the
bench press was 315 and I think back in
them days I was benching like foursome
it's like yeah man y'all come to the gym
Metroflex you know you got a lot of
Weights in there I'm like okay so the
next day I go to the gym
and the owner Brian is like man I had 22
inch arms back there almost all muscle I
was like man a big big guy you you are
competing I'm like no dude I've never
competed the day of my life and I uh
don't want to compete either
and you're like why I'm like well I
heard those dudes number one they have
to diet and uh I don't want to do no
diet because I'm used to eating you know
hamburgers and pizza
and uh Sloppy Joe's stuff like that
and then uh I also heard that they had
to take steroids you know me being a
place so I can't do none of that kind of
stuff
second day I come in and he's still
laughing like dude man you you should
really get this bodybuilding thing you
know
a Sean he's like you you could be a
world champion you could be Mr Olympia
I'm like no dude I already told you I'm
not really interested interested in it
he's like okay what a third day he's
still on me
and I'm still turning him down so the
fourth day he's like I tell you I know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give him an
ultimatum they didn't he can't refuse so
the fourth day I come in they say dude
it's like I really think you can do real
good at this bodybuilding stuff he's
like I tell you what he said I give you
a free membership to the gym
if you competed in this show come out in
like four months since I got out to try
to train as a bodybuilder I teach y'all
to die in I teach y'all to pull I teach
you everything you need to know and you
can work out in this gym for free how is
that I'm like dude you should live with
that
and uh
he did he taught me how to train at the
bodybuilder you know because it's
totally different from what I was doing
and he taught me how to pose just to go
to this guy's house like two or three
times a week and have these two hour
posing session and he taught me how to
diet you know how to you know eating
five six meals a day because I'm used to
eating like three four three yeah so it
seems like throughout your life free has
been something that's gotten your
attention where do you think that
started when I was real young and I was
poor
every time somebody said something about
free and and I was uh didn't have the
money and just to pay for it you know I
didn't want used money to pay for it you
had my attention
you mentioned free you pretty much got
me oh gosh so when you applied for the
first bodybuilding competition how much
work goes into that what's the cost of
that because I'd imagine it would get
very expensive for the the amount of
food that you would be eating and for
the amount of training and just like all
the attention that you're putting on
yourself that's why I had those other
jobs I would say I worked at Denny's
every Friday and Saturday night and
sometimes work at Western Warehouse at
Boost store
on on my on my days off you know and
then I worked for my apartment complex
and uh those three jobs almost four you
can't please bought me they helped me
out they helped me out a lot because
like I said you know diet food was real
expensive you know all the stuff you had
to buy
and then uh supplements Brian pretty
much gave me for free
and it was a lot because at least like
every two or three months you know what
I had to have all these aminos these
proteins multivitamins minerals
all this new stuff they was coming out
with Vanadium sulfate and all these new
things that they had on the market
and you know help put on muscle back in
those days Brian gave me all that for
free
and uh
it helped out a whole lot you must have
been saving a lot of money though
because you had multiple different
sources of income I wasn't saving a dime
every time I got back into your oh my on
my body because the chicken chicken was
expensive but you had to eat half
chicken breast turkey was the expense
you had had turkey breast
and uh you had to eat five six times a
day you know they use constantly buying
a lot of chicken a lot of Turkey
me I was eating fish back then so it was
a lot of fish you know it was a lot of
food a lot of rice a lot of potatoes you
know you was constantly buying all this
healthy food and it was real expensive
and uh I had a car note
how much you think you were spending
back then oh man I was spending yeah I
was making
I don't spending at least probably a
good extra
ten thousand dollars just on food really
yeah but once I started eating six times
a day and eating more
because I used to eat I didn't know at
the time I used to eat like 10 12 ounces
of food you know it was like
is
steak chicken turkey
and then I had this nutrition it's like
dude you you ain't eating enough I'm
like what like you gotta if you want to
get bigger you got to eat more I'm like
how much more he's like at least four or
five ounces more than what you're eating
I'm like what he's like yeah and uh he
was right as soon as I started went from
like 10 ounces to 16 ounces that's when
I started putting on sides really but it
was so hard to eat that much food
and then I didn't have enough time in
the day because I was working full time
so what I had what I had to do is get up
in the middle of the night
eat and go back to bed
so I I you know I slept you know like
six hours a day I would wake up at I go
to bed at like
four because I was up you know once I
got off from work I was up doing
cardio and you know still trying to get
all my
uh the rest of the stuff I had to do for
the day so I'll go to bed from like four
and I wake up at seven I would eat from
seven to eight
and wake up at eight
and uh do my I mean work up I sleep from
eight to eleven so seven and eight eat
then eight to eleven sleep and wake up
at 11 to uh do cardio
eat and work out and then go to work why
do cardio and then eat it seems like the
two would kind of cancel each other out
well see you did cardio on an empty
stomach because yes that's when you're
body is in this real high state of
burning calories
kind of like a catabolic state so you
wanna do your cardio as soon as you wake
up like I had a treadmill right beside
my bed I get out of bed and get right on
it every morning unbelievable yep I'm
curious if the interrupted sleep could
adversively affect your gains no none
whatsoever I did it for every last
Olympia that I won
[Music]
to be honest with you that's when I
started winning
when I started doing that but I heard
that sleep is one of the most crucial
parts of getting gains and recovering
and letting your muscles like get back
to where they were that's why I got a
good six hours of sleep in every single
day see
by the time you know I lay down I was
I was snowing like three minutes later
every single time I went to sleep even
when I woke up and went back to bed and
I was snowing three minutes later yeah
three hours of REM sleep just knock out
riding my mind
so you naturally seem to function
perfectly off of six hours of sleep I
need eight minutes yeah I was I was born
Lucky in it I only needed six and that's
all I was able to get to because like I
said I had a lot of stuff to do
throughout the day did you end up buying
your chicken and poultry and stuff like
that from just a normal grocery store or
did you find a different place where you
could Source the food for a discount
because you're buying so much of it I
would try to you know give it like a
discount you know if I bought so much so
I would go to the store like hey man get
like 20 pounds of you know steak uh and
give it at a discount because back then
it was like it's like almost twenty
dollars a pound and he's like yeah I'll
cut you a little so like I give you two
you're like 15 pounds if you bought like
20 20 pounds at once yeah okay cool same
thing with chicken you know yeah so
that's what I did I bought a lot at once
best thing about it is my mom cooked all
my food so it was kind of like
I was only diet but the food was so good
she was so such a good Chef that they
didn't seem like I was eating diet food
she was the best cooker ever
known to this day I was under the
understanding that if you're a
bodybuilder and you eat the same Foods
over and over and over again eating food
is more so treated like a chore and a
responsibility than it is something that
you can get enjoyment from because it's
just like it's work so so you eat you
eat you're eating for survival
yeah so you don't really care about the
taste a whole lot but taste is pretty
good because it makes the make you want
to do it
but uh like I said my mom was like the
best cook ever I mean I I didn't really
know I was gonna I couldn't tell I was
on the diet and I would play this game
with myself like you know for potatoes
instead of eating just regular baked
potato I would get a crinkle cutter and
cut it up to make it look like a french
fry and I would put it in the oven
and uh on
after about an hour of being in there it
kind of looked like a french fry it was
golden brown you know
so I'm like okay I'm eating french fries
now and people actually thought I was
eating french fries how you eat french
fries on the diet uh that's a secret
now at what point though did you realize
that working out and eating healthy
wasn't enough if you wanted to win Mr
Olympia that was these then oh
when I didn't Place well and
[Music]
um
it was it was a while before I once I
turned Pro that you know I started
facing a little bit better when I was an
amateur of course I won just about every
shot in it you know but once I turned
Pro
it was a while see I turned Pro in 91.
in my first pro at 92 I won my first
show 95 so 92 93 94 like three years
almost it took me what were the biggest
differences because I heard you say that
you walked you were talking to another
bodybuilder who said here's what I'm on
and if you want to get to my size this
is what I recommend why would they just
give away their secrets it's because it
seems to me like this would be a very
closely guarded thing that people
wouldn't want to explain what they're on
uh you know any enhancements that
they're doing because they wouldn't want
someone else to compete oh you make a
very valid point there
uh I guess the guys you know that I grew
up with you know
to be honest with you I guess they
figured that hey
everybody's body is different and um
everybody's body is going to respond
differently to different things
and then just because I'm telling you
this don't necessarily mean that you're
going to do it you know yeah so there's
you know it all depends on the person
everybody's gonna make a decision about
what they are willing to do and not do
yeah
so uh and then you know you gotta look
at it too then
the guy that you're giving the
information to even though
you're going to be up there on stage
with them it's not like you're making
the decision about who where everybody's
going to place you know they have judges
that's going to really make the final
decision about how everybody places and
everything
so I guess that's just what you most of
them looked at it because yeah guy named
Flex wheeler he taught me a whole lot
and uh had it not been for some of the
things that he taught me
uh
I really
probably wouldn't
have done is well I know for a fact I
wouldn't have done it as good as I did
and uh then then again two
God has a plan for each and every single
one of us yeah if something I've always
believed that something is meant to
happen
and it is uh God's plan for it to happen
is going to happen yeah no regardless of
where that information comes from
I believe that you know
certain things that are destined to
happen are going to happen regardless
yeah eventually you know I agree with
that one way or another was there a
specific moment that you can point to
where you realize not only are you
obviously like a pro bodybuilder and
you're really successful but at an elite
level like in the top 10 or something
where it's like it's a serious uh
accomplishment like a something Elite
rather than like because you grew up
your entire life people were
complimenting you saying you had a great
physique saying you should compete but
that's a big difference from like like
you know Ronnie Coleman like I said that
passion you know you have about doing
certain things
you're never really working a day in
your life you know I was having so much
fun
doing what I was doing
I didn't really look at it like that you
know of course you know the competitive
side of you wants to do the very best
you can or let me say competitive side
if you want to win if you show you in
you know
but the realistic side of you is like
well some things are not possible so
you gotta kind of like to take the good
with the bad if you're doing something
you really truly love doing
and uh bodybuilding was something that I
truly love doing and look forward to
doing it you can see each and every
single day working for the police
department was something that I enjoyed
doing and look forward to doing each and
every single day a lot of people used to
ask me all the time man how do you do
how do you work a full-time job and do
this bodybuilding thing there's no way I
could work a job
and do bodybuilding I like
yeah that's that's that's a pretty good
question but
you know I look forward to you know
doing my job look forward to going
uh to work at the police department you
know when I have to go and uh those are
things that I love doing and so
if there's a will
there's always a way and I made a way
and then I have people like what I would
ask me like so how do you do it
I said well it goes back to that saying
that there's a will there's the way
so I figured uh if I could work
in the same area that I lived in I can
always go home and eat a meal because
like I said when I was at work I had to
eat two meals at work because I worked
in the same area area that I lived in
it only took me 15 minutes to eat a meal
because uh you know
you're real hungry when it's time to eat
and when you real hungry it don't take
long to put down some food and I'm only
eating like chicken and rice and that's
it you know
it don't take
uh 10 minutes top for me to eat that we
get two 15-minute breaks
if time allows and a 45 minute lunch
break in my job if time allowed yeah but
there were times that you know I'd be
eating my lunch dispatch is like
I need you to clear that lunch and take
this call okay so I had to tell you know
in the middle of taking that bite
together clear launching go answer the
call and you're gonna get that you know
get a lunch break that day
now I know that you were a police
officer very far into your bodybuilding
career so you're a huge guy showing up
and and you know it's breaking up fights
or showing up on the scene and stuff
like that I'm guessing that in and of
itself disarmed any potential threats
you know some guy's acting violent you
show up and he's just like you know what
quit it I'm sorry yeah put the handcuffs
on exactly don't touch me yeah they said
mere presence of of the unit uniform
itself is the
um you know creates peace but when you
320 pounds and you show up in that
uniform
it's insta instant peace yeah was that
was that the case with oh did so did
other officers notice this that when you
would show up people they're there and
they kind of like misleaded yeah I feel
like that would make so much more sense
for us
yeah there were a lot of officers that
were smaller than me that had fights
especially girls they had fights all the
time my whole 15-year career I I didn't
have not one fight not one not one and
I'm every day and I'm like okay this is
gonna be the day he wanted him
every day I get to work and like it's
gonna be the day I have somebody an
ignorant person you know uh challenge me
you know so yeah nope they won today who
would do that though
nobody never did it I'm like oh man it's
not a coincidence it's obviously not a
coincidence yeah but I feel like that
would be great for the police
departments to now enforce in some
capacity like hey you have to be really
strong and maintain your your Peak
Physical profile so you can disarm
certain situations and not have to like
just intimidation
yeah a lot of stuff is against the law
though you know yeah yeah you can't do
that yeah I just said I mean it would
make sense
you know it'd probably be a lot of
people I think that's why bouncers are
off like me yeah all the bouncers that
you see outside of the like the best
clubs they're all like six foot four and
ripped yeah they're not gonna hire again
yeah in front of the club you know
what's funny is I heard that you you
know you never got into a fight you're
15 years in the police department no but
you did get into it working Denny's
right yep
what was that guy thinking he didn't see
me or he wasn't thinking no
turned to me
and uh to say he was walking out the
door actually getting ready to walk out
and I was eight never he never saw him
he was drunk of course you know first of
all he never saw me just sitting there
and uh he's getting ready to walk out
doing I'm like hey guys I need you to
calm down and of course
he didn't see me all he heard was a
voice and he's like whatever
so
I went and uh grabbed him by the arm
and he pulled away and that was the
biggest mistake he ever made in his
whole life because I tried to break his
arm and his leg
and his and his face
and uh
when uh when I finished with him he was
bleeding from the mouth
no and uh he had trouble with his arm
and uh
matter of fact he uh he complained he
wrote a letter and complained on me and
filed police brutality against me
but when I was uh in college I was
sports editor so I was real good at
writing and I took every technique that
they taught me at the police department
and I used it in my my narrative yeah so
you know
to
[Music]
tell you know why I did what I did
and because you know I was a pretty good
sports there and and a pretty good
writer you know for the newspaper
College Newspaper they uh wanted they
actually used mine uh narrative
narrative that I wrote
my rebuttal that I wrote you know when
this guy tried to say you know
I think you know I used excessive force
and uh they used my uh my narrative
training the recruits
um
yeah but you did not really that good
because I remember you know everything
that I was taught you know and I was
uh when I was sports editor
and uh
so needless to say that went nowhere
now I'm curious then after winning the
first Olympia how much do you make from
something like that like what changes
financially when that happens are people
throwing deals your way is there like a
cash prize I've always been curious
about that the biggest thing I got from
winning the Olympia was the endorsement
of the prize money for winning Olympia
100 000 of that but nothing
you know I did use my you'd have to pay
off my house but the big money came from
endorsements you know other stuff that I
did and like I had a supplement contract
you know
uh clothing contract I had a shoe
contract so all the money all the real
money come from endorsement yeah do you
remember back then how much that was
combined it was pretty close to a
million dollars yeah back in what year
was this 2000 I won my first Olympia in
98 okay yeah
and of course you know I was I was I had
I had quite a few endorsements though
and then you know I had a personal
appearances I was doing you know so it
was it was
it was it was it was in the million do
you remember what you spent the money on
were you were you Frugal after that
point because you always come from I I I
saved a lot and put in in retirement
like I said you know I'll be uh getting
a retirement check I think at the end of
this year
uh and from one of those and and when I
turned 60 next year I get my police
retirement and then uh you know Social
Security I put I put money in it I put a
lot of money into that also so I'll uh
I'll be pretty pretty much set for for
life you know
now at what point then after winning did
people start recognizing you when you
would walk in as a police officer I know
to wait a second are you Ronnie is that
you I've seen you and they just like
they put down what they were stealing
yeah
yeah because uh you know everybody was
doing stories on me uh CNN was doing
Stories the local
News Channel all of them you know I did
so much with so many different news
stations
paper back then you know they had a lot
of magazine stuff you know I did a lot
of magazine I did uh
a lot of radio I did a lot of radio
so back then you know I became known for
that you know you do talk shows like Jay
Leno and uh
Montel
Roseanne had this show I did
so uh I was I was pretty popular you
know and still and today you know I
think I'm more popular now than I was
because of social media social media you
know they didn't have that when I was
coming up you know but because of the
social media thing I'm more popular
today with uh younger crowd than I am
like I was just in a store
um uh right before I came here when we
was at Chipotle getting man I think this
kid had to be no more than eight years
old like I I saw you on Tick Tock a tick
tock yeah you know the guy take a
picture and I get that a lot though and
then uh like when I was I just recently
in uh Italy and
most of the kids that came up to me were
like Junior High in high school
so I think one of the people that was
that I asked the kid out you know him
and they're like yeah it was something
on Tick Tock or we saw him on YouTube or
something yeah so and I so I say because
of you know social medium a lot more
like
three times more
known than I was back then so do you say
then you're making more money now than
you were way more really
way way more now than I did back then do
you mind sharing how much you were
making when you were winning Olympia
multiple times in a row a little over
a million you know when I was winning
the Olympia
then you know now I make
millions from different sources you know
like the YouTube I got my own supplement
company yeah yeah I have a closing
endorsement you know
but it's mostly from social social media
for you doing social media does that
feel like work or is it something that
you would do for free like the other
things but you just happened to make
money off of it it's something I would
do for free because this I mean what am
I doing just talking about stuff
yeah I mean yeah that's not working I
loved it in a video that you said I
think it was a documentary where you
said you go to work and most people
would say you know another another day
another dollar but you said another day
another quarter another day
another quarter yeah how much money you
were making bodybuilding yeah working
with Police Department exactly do you
why I know you say you enjoyed it so
much but I did it just because you
enjoyed it just because I enjoy it and
uh you know for me it was like an escape
from it also you know it allowed me not
to think about it and have it on my mind
all the time you know just worrying
about that yeah one thing
called you know when somebody's out to
try to kill you you know you got a lot
more to worry about than uh when your
next meal or when you next workout yeah
and when did you decide to make the
shift into social media and why because
it seems like you were at a point where
it's like you could do anything in the
world you don't need to do anything for
money anymore I mean it was kind of like
one of those things that that was
evident obvious you know uh there was
the thing that everybody was doing you
know so because everybody's doing it
it's only a naturally and natural for
you to do it too you know I never forget
uh when uh what was that uh Instagram
came out you know they already had
Facebook and some other ones and
probably my space before that you need
to sign up for this Instagram thing I'm
like no I got enough on my plate to be
worried about uh Instagram she's like
well I'm gonna sign you up for it myself
and just because she did that you know
I'm I'm wearing that today because of
that you know she decided she's gonna
sign me up for it anyway if I wasn't
going to sign it because I really wasn't
gonna sign up for it because I'm like
you know I got enough you know I'm gonna
email that I can barely keep up with
this Facebook thing I can barely keep up
with
why do I want to you know
add to what I don't have enough time for
anyway but uh you know it came obvious
after a while that if uh
you really wanna
monetize
your work and make the most you can this
is the way to do it yeah and it is so
easy to do
I'm sure everything is easy it's got to
be easy compared to what you were going
through yeah
growing up uh I had some pretty hard
jobs just one job I had in Louisiana
it was called chopping cotton
is but it's not what you think yeah
because when they first told me it was
going to be chopping cotton I'm thinking
okay I got to go out there and and chop
the cotton yeah
no you got to go out there and you gotta
chop the grass from around the cotton so
we don't so the machine well when it
comes along and picks it you know they
had Machine by the time when the machine
comes along and pick it don't pick up
the grass too
that was the hardest job ever because
you out there from six in the morning
until 12 noon they will not let you work
past that because you will die
you would have literally died no matter
how much water you're drinking
cause uh
you know have you ever seen cotton the
way they planted well it's like
it's about a mile long yeah the rose of
it it's about a mile on you so you had
to walk from one end all the way down to
the other end
and you bent over and you're in the sun
there's no shade nowhere
because the only way for cotton to grow
it had to be sun no shade and so all the
fields are out there and then Louisiana
you think 108 well I forget we in
California I live in Texas yeah yeah
right it's 108 every day we're in Vegas
about the same but you guys have
humidity yeah it's different the
humidity in Texas is not as bad as it is
in Louisiana it's like a hundred percent
every single day it's actually feels
like you are in a stove right working
yeah inside of it every single day
that's how hot it was out there but of
course after a while you kind of get
used to it too because I'll never forget
the time I left
you know uh Louisiana and move to Texas
and it was about maybe three years
before I came back and when I came back
and I hit Louisiana I stepped out of the
car and that heat hit me I'm like wow I
never knew how hot it was how humid it
was out here until now
because it's like I stepped out of my
car and stepped into an oven
that's how hot it is in Louisiana where
I'm from the humidity in Texas is
nothing compared to so then that raised
the threshold for what you consider
difficult it's like you compare it yeah
yeah that yeah and that was another job
I worked we had a jackhammer
and uh
they had they had these uh paper mills
and for some reason another they would
use as asbestos or something because you
know they are working with all these
chemicals and so they have to have
everything insulated in these paper
mills that job we were
literally had on a suit
the whole time we were working full
Hazard suit breathing oxygen with this
Jackhammer just eight hours a day that's
a hard that's that's hard work
um chopping cotton that's the hardest
work ever nothing's harder than that and
you think those social media I would
consider that work see I think social
media could be more of a mentally taxing
thing because at least for me I'm always
thinking about it like my mind never
shuts off every waking moment is
thinking YouTube titles thumbnails
strategy Trends Non-Stop
I got jobs I can I can compare social
media to uh growing up in Louisiana yeah
you know that was one job I had now
working in the restaurant
uh washing dishes
for eight hours
um I've had some pretty good job pretty
bad jobs yeah pretty bad jobs why did
you stay at the Cotton Place like what
was the motivation of staying there if
it was it was grueling labor you've ever
had they paid you real good for that
yeah if minimum wage was a dollar an
hour they paid you like four dollars an
hour oh wow so you like oh okay yeah
sign me up for that job that makes sense
yeah and they did they paid you real
good
but it was hard it was the hardest work
I've ever done do you think that helped
build character for where you are today
for the most part I don't see it like
this I've always
enjoyed money for some reason or another
so I've always found a way to make it
yeah I think I started my first job when
I was like eight years old I would uh
sweep the parking lot of the
neighborhood
grocery store and then I would mop
inside and then I would stock drinks
they paid me a quarter a day
and back then you know this 70s all
right that was a lot of money because
you could buy a lot with a quarter you
buy Snickers soda was a nickel you could
buy a soda
cookies oh man it went a long ways I
remember my my Grandpa would tell me all
the things that he could buy with a
nickel yeah
back in like the 1930s but he would say
you go to the candy store with a nickel
and you'd be able to buy whatever you
want and like you get like bags of candy
for anything yeah that's the way a
quarter was for me yeah yeah so that was
a lot and
I I've always worked you know I had jobs
where I would mow yards knocking people
do it you need your own mode yeah
I did that for a long time in Louisiana
they have pecan trees everywhere I would
always just go to a tree and just throw
a stick up there and and knock admit it
down as I could and they would buy them
from you at the liquor store yeah so I
did that job and then Coke bottles
recycling did well you can call it that
they would give you like a nickel for
for you you took the coke bottle the
most grocery store did that you brought
them in there yeah so I I oh man in so
many ways I can make money in so many
ways I did make money yeah at one time
when I was in high school I had three
jobs I was working the clock
for the intramural games I was working
at that store
uh you know stocking the drinks and
everything clean up and I worked at a
restaurant
um went washing dishes and you know
cleaning tables and stuff like that I
had three jobs that I was doing at one
time in high school what were you
spending the money on are we just saving
it I was spending the money on clothes
come on man I wasn't saving nothing I
was spending every nickel a dime I made
on either clothes or food I I've always
eaten ate a lot I've always eaten a lot
so I was always eating and I you know I
didn't depend on my mom for you know on
these things you know I was kind of like
a
in the independent contractor as a kid
I'm pretty much made my own money
because I didn't want to buy the shoes
that you know she would buy for us yeah
I didn't want to wear clothes that you
would buy for us I bought my own you
know did any party you want to save that
though just knowing that like hey you
didn't grow up for money so you should
save more of it or were you just like
I'll just make more I didn't really have
a reason to save back then because like
I said it
I had needs of my own like like I said I
didn't want to buy I didn't want to wear
what she wanted to buy me so I bought my
own stuff and I made my own money and
like I said I ate a lot back then
a whole lot I've always eaten a whole
lot of my whole entire life so where did
this intensity and wantingness to work
and push yourself and Excel and
everything that you did because you said
you graduated laude you applied to a
hundred jobs you were an intense lifter
ever since you were like 12 years old
you've continued not only to excel but
also to have this this crazy high level
of dedication and focus towards every
single thing that you do in life and
where does this come from was it
something that was instilled to you by
your parents or was it just like you
think it's an innate thing you were born
with it it was something that I was born
with I was always
trying to be the best at everything that
I was that I did I was always
challenging myself to be the best at
everything it was that I did because
being the best
[Music]
um
the rewards were greater
you know and uh I always challenged
myself at everything that I did
everything even if I was you know
playing a pickup game of cards
Checkers chess anything I was always
challenging myself to be the best at
everything that I did same thing and and
cause like like you were saying you know
if I wasn't the smartest guy in every
class I went to
I would always study with the smartest
guy like who's who's in here who in here
in this class is smarter than me
most most the time I was this morning
sometimes I wouldn't so I'm like okay if
I learn from him I can be you know like
him yeah and and I've always challenged
myself like that everything I've always
did not like like you said it's kind of
like that
inevitability that I was kind of like
born with why do you feel like you had
to push yourself to be the best all the
time because like I said is that that um
is that feeling the uh
uh you know the rewards you get
basically yeah what are the rewards are
so much better well let's see if I'm if
I would uh
this morning you know it's something you
know
it was always a challenge thing to me
you know saying to myself that I I I
accomplished this and so it's kind of
like of a personal Vendetta I have
Within Myself for the most part if
you're not the best at something you can
always become better
is always the way that you can either
outwork somebody or out think them
and uh that's kind of the way like the
way I looked at by the building
you know when I first got into it I
wasn't that good because I really didn't
know that much I figured that you know
if I could
do things that certain people won't do
uh I can be just as good as they are was
it difficult for you transitioning out
of professional bodybuilding knowing
that like this is the one thing that you
were like the best in the world that
many years in a row and and then not
doing that was that like it's got to be
a huge shock yeah in a way it was
because you know you're entering in into
a different field something that you're
don't know a lot about but it was the
same way with bodybuilding you know I
didn't know a lot about that and
eventually I learned you know
and like I said uh if you're not the
smartest
you can always learn from somebody who
he is
and uh that's pretty much how I look
looked upon life to my whole entire life
are you taking the same approach now
with social media oh yeah
I take the same approach with just about
everything I do yeah uh
I figure
if there's a will and there's a way and
with me there is always a will you've
done you've done some really interesting
collaborations recently I love the video
with Jesse James West oh yeah yeah we
have a lot of fun and
um I was sent some of your breakdowns in
terms of the businesses that you run and
it's it's surprising to me because
everything is so separate and everything
is like it stands in its own leg from
your YouTube and Facebook earnings over
a million a year
appearance is 300 000 a year
so a lot of hot appearances how often
are you doing appearances man there was
times that I would leave my house for
three months
she is 365 days in a year right so out
of those 365 days I was gone 300 days
just doing appearances or doing
appearances how do you manage because my
thought is that like that's one of the
least earning parts of your business but
it takes it seemingly takes the most
amount of time is that worth it to you
or is it more so about you getting in
front of fans
if it wasn't worth it I wouldn't be
doing it
so it was definitely worth it yeah yeah
but then we also have apparel two
million dollars a year
Coleman Athletics yeah sponsorship deals
another one and a half and this is the
one that I was telling Jack that I was
shocked about 750
000 a year doing Cameo
I am alone you could make that much
money that's correct that is
so cool oh my God I have about 10 of
those things holding right now I was
doing them up in my room I used to come
down here yeah how many do you get per
day oh man sometimes I can get 10 a day
yeah and how much are they for per Cameo
300 300 that's amazing no that is 10 of
them amazing so I'm on so I'm on camera
I think it's gonna take that long to do
it you know how long does it take say
happy birthday or happy anniversary
so I'm on Cameo what advice do you have
for me mine is 175 for a cameo and I
maybe get one a week oh man me but I
don't push it do you do you like
advertise The Cameo all the time or
people just find it because it's like
you just find it I don't advertise it at
all imagine what you could do if you
advertise yeah I know well now that
we're talking about it
because I'm also on memo too
which is the same thing as Cameo yeah
so you know
uh yeah if I advertise I wouldn't be
able to keep up with it for sure that's
incredible 10.
you just you must grow desensitize it if
I'm getting 10 a day I'm like
I I would be excited yeah there's a
wheel there's a way
then we got live signings another 300
000 a year
um and then hosting bodybuilding shows
350 and this is what I find really
interesting is your supplement company
that's projected to do 30 million
dollars in Revenue this year yeah yeah
you should so we started at it though so
tell us about what a 12th year I think
13th year when did you start doing
supplements and what what prompted you
to get into that how do you design it
how do you make that well see I started
with supplements uh back in
1994 I think I got my first contract
well I was with two or three different
other companies
and uh I saw the The Profit they were
making I'm like man hmm
if I'm making them this kind of money
what kind of money can I make myself if
I got into it and that's how I got into
it and how were those first few years
for your supplement everybody extremely
tough like I said those were the years I
was gone 300 days because I had so many
appearances to do and you know you know
my supplement business is probably 80
International and 20 domestic really
yeah because we started the company
internationally
we didn't even do domestic for some
years why did you choose to only open is
way more popular international
what countries just about anywhere
really anywhere else in the world I I've
gone to places like India and field the
whole entire mall with people the whole
why do you think that is Brazil the same
thing the whole entire month you look
and you see all these levels of people
it's kind of mind-blowing I I have
pictures of some of it but yeah I
probably couldn't find it if I try but
uh it's so like I was just one time I
was in uh Bulgaria
and I was with the president uh opening
chess tournament
opening gym yeah you know I I don't
think I've even
met a president here in the United
States
but in another country I can be with one
I've met
in several different countries I met the
president of the country and hung out
with him that's wild why is it so much
bigger internationally than here in the
United States because internationally
they don't have any bodybuilders really
they really and truly don't the all the
great bodybuilders come from the United
States you know they every every every
now and then you know like uh Miss
Olympia now uh is a guy from Iran you
know before that
uh other only other Mr Olympia that I
can think of right now that was from
another country if I thought back
foreign
six from England but you know after that
I can't think of any other guy that won
the Olympia because but of course you
know there are other bodybuilders in
these countries but they're just not you
know on the same level that we are it's
like God's like come on man
put all the great bodybuilders in
America
why I don't know but that's seems like
that's the way it is so that's why we
launched our company in uh Spain really
in 2011. do you think part of that has
to do with the unhealthy diet culture in
America and how we're a very obese
country
don't care so much about that and in
other areas like you know people I don't
know they're healthier I think that has
a lot to do with it I saw something in
Twitter earlier today that was comparing
the average meal for a middle school
student in the United States versus that
of a middle school student in France and
the differences were Aston I mean the
Americans had all the fried food
processed food the Italians were eating
like salads grapes carrots like a
chicken breast or like fish it's like
you don't have that that seriously
there's a thing of salmon on a plate
that's fun like the average do you even
just think that like someone Middle
School's having fish and then you can
see how many obese people they are in
these other countries too you know like
China I mean
um I jacked them a whole bunch you know
countries you know
compared to us how many obese people
there are
yeah but uh you know it's I guess it's
the culture the most part that's what I
think when's the last time you had
McDonald's probably when I won the
Olympia yeah yes that's my go-to meal
after every Olympia are you serious it's
been that long yeah and what do you
order I can't stand it now you you
you don't like the taste of it
you had it was that long ago that long
ago what did you order uh Double Quarter
Pounder with cheese
yeah this is this is my uh
after a celebration meal
I have pizza already in the room because
I've already had somebody to order it
and uh I've always already ordered
champagne at times
don't period we'll eat pizza in the room
for about an hour hour and a half
and then we go to McDonald's and we'll
have
um quarter pounder with cheese A couple
of them maybe oh my gosh some chocolate
chip cookies
and then uh after that
we go to strip club
the whole family the family yeah
whoever's celebrating with me that's
where we're going
everything how much would you spend
there who cares
you just lost track who cares
I just won
with the strippers recognize you as you
walk and be like hey that's you just won
no because they they are they it's dark
in there first of all you know and they
have certain clients that they uh used
to dealing with most of them are oh no
not really and they don't really know
how would they treat you being like such
a big guy walking in there did you get
like special treatment or like what he
would need three whatever if it's a
small one yeah yeah I I get real special
treatment if it's a big one like the one
in Vegas uh they don't even know there's
me
plus I had my whole family with me my
mom
[Music]
my my my my sisters my aunt yeah my
brother I can see your brother but like
why the whole family why not just say
like you know that you know
when together it hangs together would
you buy them like dances like your mom
and your sister what are they coming
with you for just to hang out you have
to hang out they just hang out
wow
it's like I'd get awkward I couldn't do
it oh yeah you got a mom like mine
my mom is known for partying every
single night of the week
so do you only then go to strip clubs
once you win yeah
if you were to lose would you not go to
a strip club oh yeah because I I think
the year I lost we still we still went
[Laughter]
win or lose I'm curious because this may
sound like a an odd question but I'm
just so fascinated when you're that
ripped that huge that muscular do you
think that you have more success with
the ladies than somebody who's like
ripped but not like I mean like traps or
like you know six inches off your
shoulders you know like no doubt
you have more success when you're that
no doubt interesting I don't know I
wouldn't these basketball players they I
think they they may have have me beat
some maybe some of the football players
too
talking to some of those guys uh they
they get a lot of attention too
uh so I think for the most part I think
Sports where they can see your face you
know get most of the tension because you
know I don't know about the football
players but they wear their helmets and
stuff so it's kind of hard and you know
to see especially like a guy that's you
know blocking you know for somebody yeah
Steve making the money and everything
but he doesn't have his face out there
that he always has on that helmet now
the guy's catching the ball you know
they when they catch they take that hit
one yeah
you gotta run in the bowling yeah soon
and of course the quarterback saying
those guys you know I think they they
also real popular with the women now how
would you balance everything you're
doing with also like having a family
relationships how do you find the time
problem
[Music]
well do you prioritize like one thing at
a time or like one over another like
right now I gotta work out this is my
priority yeah I'm always proud to
prioritizing you know
uh work out and uh work came became
before anything yeah
yeah so there were times where
like when I'm in Camp get ready for a
show they know not to even come by my
house first of all I'm in a bad mood
always
and I don't really know it that I'm in a
bad mood because it's normal for me to
act like that a certain way you know
because I'm so focused you know you
can't lose track of
certain things and your attitude is one
of them and then uh
they already know you know that uh
when it's training camp come the I'm in
training camp
there's no partying there's no
hanging out there's no going in the
movies there's no birthday parties
there's no nothing everything is
uh revolved around you know getting
ready for the show for the most part and
how long would you be in that mindset
for I'll say three months okay sometimes
four I heard Floyd Mayweather is the
exact same way yeah before a fighter
when you have to be he just zones in you
can't talk to him no one's around him he
is just in that zone 24 7. yep 24 7.
don't go nowhere
don't really do too much nothing you
know
and uh that's just the way it is yeah
and after your performances let's say
you win a Mr Olympia you said that you
celebrate for a day what's it look like
after that one night are you still gonna
continue eating for a little bit back to
being a one day off one day one day oh
well I wouldn't call it a day off
because you just won you know you he's
working earlier that day yeah so it's
it's a few hours off
and then it's back to business yeah yeah
how did having your first daughter
change your outlook on life I was in
college when that happened and uh really
didn't give it a lot of thought
because my mind was on you know making
money and
and building a career yeah so it really
wasn't
a good thing for me sure
and uh it was a bad thing for you if you
asked me
and if you ask her too she'll tell you
uh how how
that
particular person and now of course it's
different you know yeah you know once
once once you know
of uh been successful yeah it's it's a
lot different yeah
it does kind of like change you in a way
you know but I've I've had uh
after I won the Olympia I think I had
four
girls like back to back yeah
the first one was uh 11 I think
being 13 14
15.
just that quick did you did you ever
look into this of why you would only
have daughters is that just like a coin
flip and it just happened to flip the
hills like multiple times in a row like
what are the chances of that no God has
certain purposes for certain people in
life
and mine was the populate the Earth with
daughters only yeah
they know other they there's no debating
it there's seven
seven dollars eight eight yeah these are
amazing no Sons none you'd think that
you'd have just like an inordinate
amount of like testosterone and like
yeah why chromosomes or whatever number
six did you not go to the doctor and say
like hey look or it's six dollars in a
row what's going on what's going on it's
gotta be no because I always thought it
was gonna be a son you know every time
until the last one I'm like okay it
ain't gonna happen was there but was
there a desire to try for number nine
and like hey maybe the night
she's like I'm getting this stuff out of
me so I don't have any more and she is
that was number six for her
you gotta try again did you keep trying
because you because you wanted to try to
get a son eventually eventually like you
were at before and you're like all right
we'll try one more we'll get a daughter
like okay okay one more sign yeah
exactly every time and you're like this
is the one this is the one no this is
one nope like oh man they ain't gonna
happen at any time if if you had a son
was the goal for your son to kind of
like get into bodybuilding as well and
like carry your names
to be you know just like me yeah I grew
up
and call my own
destiny that you know God put me on yeah
for the most part because the one I
wanted that didn't happen
I always thought I was going to be a
professional football player because I
had so much fun and then enjoyed it so
much but uh it wasn't meant to be yeah
it was not meant to be it's interesting
even with uh Arnold's I think he has two
sons
Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah one I think
is really into bodybuilding the other's
not yeah exactly and it's just kind of
my opinion yeah it's just up to them how
they want to pursue just whatever they
want I think that's the best way you can
do to go through life yeah like
he is beating who they want to be in
because like I said you know
really not up to you yeah it's really
not how are you as a father did do you
ever meet the boyfriends is they you
know brought them to you and what was
that like
I try not to meet them really I try not
to meet them because uh
I don't want to be friends with you know
and then uh it don't work out yeah gotta
meet another one
they don't work out gotta meet another
one now
I'll wait till you uh get married and
Men maybe you know
maybe yeah then maybe yeah yeah
but uh yeah I I didn't really
had I hadn't had that uh happen yet well
yeah well my two oldest daughters yeah
and they both got married and I I think
the one came to me and asked me and the
other one not so much and so I didn't
really care either way yeah I ain't
trying to meet you know this guy and
that guy sure I got better things to do
with my time I would just imagine it
being so intimidating yeah well
probably would be yeah because I'm
really not too nice with people I don't
really know that well yeah especially
when you're dating
[Laughter]
when you went on Rogan he brought up
stem cells to you I'm curious because I
never got to hear about a follow-up
because he wanted to refer you to his
friend Dr Riordan or reordin or
something like that was was there any
follow-through with that did any stem
cell no no I don't I I can't remember
it's been so long now that
I don't know if I was already doing it
or not but uh I know for the last at
least the last two years I almost two
years that I've been getting stem cells
and it's been the best thing that has
ever happened to me in my life
really yeah but you gotta go out of this
country to do it because they don't ever
really allow the real stem cells that
comes from the placenta you know yeah
they don't like they don't allow that
here in the United States because
politics for the most part you know pain
uh people would lose too much money
those for the most part it
wiped it wipes out the pain that I I I
go through is that just temporary it's
for regenerative too well I say it's
regenerative because I I go like every
four months where do you go uh Puerto
Vallarta Mexico really I was just there
uh yeah and uh I'll be in so much pain
like
nights and nights in a row that I can't
you know it'll wake me up and sometimes
I can't sleep I'm in so much pain
because I have a herniated disc and my
upper back still and uh
his mother is
pain areas too as soon as I get the stem
cell uh the injection it completely goes
away it's been like maybe four or five
days completely I go from not being able
to sleep to sleeping like a baby so okay
I what exactly is stem cells like like
they go and do they just take some of
the placenta juice or whatever it is and
then just inject it into you and that's
it that's it so my understanding is that
what they are they're like blank cells
they can transform to anything they
anything you surround themselves with
they'll turn into that so if you inject
them in your leg they'll turn into you
know leg cells inject it into your back
yeah they can that the first time I had
it done that's the way they did it now
they just do it IV and it I guess it
goes throughout the whole entire body
wow what would happen if so I don't have
any like like injuries or ailments or
anything like that if a normal healthy
person started taking stem cells would I
would it be like a steroid of sorts
would it make me strong or something
like that I don't they do anything
because they wouldn't have no purpose
huh you know you you gotta have a reason
to have them you know
it's like treating something that's not
there for the most part you know on a
healthy person so for you is that just
to keep keep it like a baseline or is
this for like recovery in terms of stem
cells for me is to keep the pain away
okay
and hopefully you know recovery you know
also
like I have
a lot of numbness in my feet and
in my legs
but uh a lot of it is going away and
that was in my legs
now it's
if I can get to go down to my feet the
tonight the more injection I get the
better everything else gets the numbness
and everything gets too
and how much is it yeah that's how
expensive it's stem cell
um I happen to be lucky so so I don't
pay sorry
that makes sense
yeah how much would it be
uh I think he told me what did he tell
me now I gotta think because I've never
had to pay so I think he says it's about
twenty eight hundred per injection time
you go and your injection yeah in the
United States though I think it was
either Rogan or you mentioned this about
it being like twenty thousand dollars in
the United States if you want it and
it's not as good yeah
I'm I'm I've never tried it in the
United States because I said they don't
really offer it yeah they'll tell you
it's some kind of stem cell but it's not
the
real one from the placenta yeah I don't
know whether that's themselves coming
from
it's better not to ask I just know yeah
it didn't it doesn't work that good
because I also I remember having it done
once and nothing you know I haven't
noticed anything
no relief whatsoever so I'm curious what
else are you doing in addition to stem
cells right now
oh just in terms of recovery body Health
the stem cells is taking care of
everything really fixing everything so I
don't have to do anything else
uh besides that really no more surgeries
or anything else you know I was going to
have another surgery on my mid back with
that with a herniated disc was
but the stem cells kind of almost healed
in really so I don't I don't need that
surgery anymore the pain is pretty much
gone I mean it was real bad at one time
it was the worst one of the worst pains
ever
that I can remember over the years I've
had you know
surgeries for the herniated discs I've
had like three or four
uh like my whole neck whole back foot
for the most part
but uh this time the stem cells healed
the herniated discs and
there's no pain and if there is you're
not saying I always go and do the stem
cell treatment and it takes it away yeah
completely away all of these injuries
that your body has incurred
um is that a just a
objective byproduct of being that high
level of performer and bodybuilding like
it's just going to happen
um
I don't know uh because I
never really injured myself in the gym
that I can recall
I remember
when I was playing football
in college I hurt my back real real bad
and uh I would I started going to the
chiropractor
and um
it started getting getting better and
better every time I went so
I I did Chiropractic
my whole College
career and then when I got out of
college I continued to go
and uh
only I can remember
injured my back once uh in the gym
but uh I heard I think I her needed this
um
a long time ago in the
it was around
1996 I think you know I kind of like
kept going to chiropractor you know
most part it it at least for me it
pretty much fixed it it healed it and
didn't have any problems with it
and uh all of a sudden you know once I
stopped doing bodybuilding and stopped
going to Chiropractic I started having
problems with my bank
and uh that's when I had to have this
first surgery was there a specific
turning point or something that happened
that kind of bound you to having a bunch
of surgeries later in life like was it
the first herniated disc or was it a
specific surgery you wouldn't understand
it was the first surgery the first
surgery you think is where you maybe
went wrong well I went wrong yeah so
what happened there well for some reason
another you know my the other this
kind of like were affected from that
first surgery it's like
you have a a bunch of cans stacked on
top of each other and you take one out
yeah and now the other ones just fall
so I I think because I operated on that
one disc
it kind of
messed up the other ones that's the only
thing I could I could
see that happen because like I said uh
it was never like I was in the gym
working out and all of a sudden I felt
the pain or something it was just that
one surgery
because
the other discs of mine to herniating
that's the only thing that's on
the solution do you think that maybe
your pain tolerance is so high that when
something is wrong it doesn't quite
register with you yeah yeah now keep
working out yep you pushing because I
remember when I herniated
this one time I was working out working
out yeah
and all of a sudden you know I stopped
and uh don't do anything
in the pain
comes
you know
and by that time it's too late because
you know I've already injured myself and
kept working out because you know like
you said the high pain tolerance I have
and um just made it worse by continuing
to you know to do what I was doing what
was that workout that you were doing
that herniated that first disc I think
it was squatting because I remember like
it was yesterday I was wanting like 600
and you know I do do that all the time
I do like 12 or 15 reps this day I was
coming from rep number eight and I heard
a loud bang
it's loud it was so loud it kind of hurt
my ear
and I remember like what was that I
turned around actually first I dumped
the way I like
you know we always like slap slap each
other to uh get each other fired up let
me get rid of the
do something real heavy and I thought
the guy had hit me you know that was
spotting me I'm like did you hit me like
no man I didn't touch you I'm like what
was that loud noise like I don't know
but I heard it too
well with me you know down to the next
exercise and that's what I did I went on
to the next exercise I finished the
workout got home
and I was on my way to work and I'm like
man I think I'm still in pain from
working out but you know
I'm always sometimes always in pain
after doing certain types of workout
like legs I I'll always be in pain for
like
an hour two hours something like that
and it'll go away oh my gosh well you
know it's not a major pain but what kind
of pain is it a soreness
kind of like a more like a sore in this
type of a pain you know and it kind of
like wears off after a while
this day it didn't wear all and I'm like
something's wrong
you know instead of going to work I'm
like I think I bet I think I better go
to the hospital and that's what it was
it was a herniated disc some was wrong
and when you were doing that squat do
you remember if like your form slipped
for a second or if it was just complete
chance that you were going down your
form was perfectly fine something went
awry and the disc herniated it was the
same form I always use
uh I don't know only thing the only
thing I could think of is
at uh did the Olympia and uh I think I
took off a week of the
I was I was out of town you know doing
stuff and
didn't get a chance to go to the gym and
and because I missed that week it
caused my body to get a little weaker
because you know I like I said I do 600
all the time for 15 reps like it ain't
like it ain't nothing
but this particular day
I think because I missed that week
it kind of decreased my strength a
little bit
throughout the Rhythm or something I
don't know what it was
all I know is
coming up on rep number eight I heard a
loud bang
and uh
that was it that was a herniated disc
how much time are you spending today
running your businesses like what's an
average day look like for you oh I'll
spin probably
is
as much time as I possibly can after I
work out
and uh I would say probably
five six hours maybe somewhere in there
yeah a day and you're making a gym right
now it's a destination gym uh well see I
had a gym uh
in my old house yeah and uh
somebody offered me some new equipment
and uh that's part of this new
endorsement I'm doing now and now I'm
going to build a new gym in this new
house that uh
I'm about to you know well I've already
moved into it but I want to build this
new gym real soon you know
when I get around to it and hopefully
that's as soon as possible so when did
you buy this house why did you why did
you move what what about this new house
was uh well I was in the house I was in
uh kind of outgrew the family
the girls are getting on up there in age
you know
and you know girls oh they got to have
their own space you know you can't
print them all in the same room yeah
like they were now they want their own
room so now we got
um bedrooms and showers for all the
girls how big is that their own it's
it's twice the size of the house I was
living in was I live over
three thousand the new houses
almost six thousand and a little over
six thousand okay hundred something like
that that's correct it's twice the house
you got to do a house tour and I think
that would be great and uh pool and you
know jacuzzi and all that stuff too
where the new house didn't the old house
didn't have all that yeah and and more
land because my you know my old house I
don't think I had nowhere near what I
have now I almost have an acre
with my old house
no I didn't even have close to
uh what a third of an acre fourth of an
acre
it was pretty small it was best after I
built the gym you know when I moved in
first moved in the house there there was
no gym there or nothing so I had a lot
more land yeah but once I built that gym
and that uh took all the room that was
you know there yeah so there was no
hardly no room whatsoever
out there in the backyard it's a little
bit in front but nothing in the back how
often do you relax or just take time for
yourself and not do anything that either
is productive or making money or like
bring value to you monetarily in some
way yeah I try to at least once a year
go on a vacation and that vacation
filmed around cruise cruise and I
started that in
1999 I took my first cruise where do you
cruise to usually Caribbean
um
Mexico and on these cruises are you
you're not working at all you're kind of
just taking it easy lounging by the pool
getting some drinks yeah
not a whole lot of working I still have
to you know take email and all that kind
of stuff and keep up with everything
that's going on and business-wise and
you look forward to that cruise every
year I look forward to that cruise every
year how long is the cruise uh uh it's
seven eight day cruise okay is it like a
Royal Caribbean yeah yeah like we've
been uh doing Carnival Carnival Cruise
well of course I've been on Royal
Caribbean and a couple of other ones too
but
lately it's been Carnival and uh you
know actually the whole family pretty
much goes when they can but when we go
is it just it's never just me and the
fam I mean my family it's me and the
whole family and my brothers and sisters
you know nieces nephews also go I mean
I'm sure you're at the point now where
you can step back from the business just
a little bit and maybe take two of those
cruises per year even three maybe well
you know we do like go to like um
yeah we got Sea World we'll go maybe
twice a year
so we'll do sea world that's only you
know like three four days here and there
and then in in the cruise so yeah yeah
it's it's a little bit more time now
how often not to just change the
conversation entirely is uh body
dysmorphia amongst bodybuilders is it
pretty much every single one of them to
some extent has a level of body
dysmorphia and dissatisfaction with
where they're at I would say so for sure
I would say so for sure do you think
it's changing right now with social
media and Instagram that it's that is
worse today than it was back when you
were doing it yeah yeah it's changing
for sure because of social media is a
lot worse now you know when I was doing
it although there's
so much more criticism criticism that's
true I didn't think about that like you
post a picture online and you have
thousands of people nitpicking yeah that
probably fuels it so much yeah people
can criticize you it reminds me of the
guy uh this is recently was it Madison
Beer posted a picture on Instagram and
some guy said uh you're looking a little
fat today I think you should lose some
weight and she commented back on him and
she said I wouldn't touch you with a
10-foot pole and then he went off he
sent her a long DM about how he's trying
to be helpful and how she would she's
trying to like help her look more
attractive but she posted the screenshot
she posted the screenshot this guy got
torn to shreds
um but I didn't think about like how
you're opening yourself up to criticism
of the entire world all it takes is one
person just like a bum at home doing
nothing with their life to comment oh I
don't like this about it yeah exactly
and there's a lot of that out there a
whole lot where like I said in my day
there was none of that none whatsoever
so how is social media changed the
bodybuilding industry do you think it's
about us to make a lot more money
in more ways than one so many different
ways you're doing a great job I think
collaborating with a lot of people right
now yeah yeah uh I'm doing pretty good
thank you you have something coming up
with Arnold yeah uh-huh yeah will be
doing one with him in the morning we got
this this workout so I think it'd be the
first time
see a guy from my era and the guy from
his era has ever done something like
this oh you know Arnold won seven
Olympians and I won eight so it it can
only be done by uh you know a few guys
anyway so what's what's the video you
guys just working out together yeah yeah
pretty much for the most part because I
think he works out every single day just
like me
uh I work out six days a week still you
know and I think he's he's still doing
the same thing too and where's he's a
little bit older than me though where is
that going to be posted probably have it
on YouTube you know yeah other places I
would lose it I would lose it everywhere
it's like seriously just go be a fly in
the wall and just watch his like Arnold
Schwarzenegger's working out I would
lose it man do you know what the workout
is quite sure we'll come up with some
pretty entertaining something
entertaining
you know between you know my
uh
eight Olympians in his seven Olympians
we will be able to come up with
something you're gonna rub that in his
face do you have one on him you have a
chance I get yeah
a little better here
every chance I get yeah yeah of course
you got to get him on scene got me as
well
and how do you feel like social media
has helped your overall businesses
because it seems like right now this
feeling a lot of the growth especially
for supplements yeah cameos
majorly in a major way yeah
has allowed us to
for sure the business is growing just
about everything else too you know and
I'll do that you know I could say
there's so many Avenues now you know so
many social media sites they got out
there now so there's so many ways to get
you know the word out to people in the
masses of people that's on there too you
know there's so many people on there and
some of these people have what 200
million followers 100 million followers
stuff like that so yeah I go to show you
how many people really into it alongside
your incredible level of focus and pain
tolerance
and um I would just say just intensity
I'm also noticing a consistent level of
optimism and positivity even in the face
of extremely tough and challenging
circumstances yep is this also something
that you feel like you were just born
with do you think that it's provided to
you through faith do you think that it's
something that you could have learned
from overcoming this adversity yep over
and over and over again because it's
optimistic I think because I've overcome
so much adversity
and they almost stick to years that I've
been on here on this planet that
that uh I'm able to overcome that much
more as long as I'm here on this planet
because of the the fight in me
it's it's not the
size of the dog in the fight but the
size of the fight in the dog
and I got quite a bit in me you have to
in order to you know be successful in
these days in time what else do you want
to accomplish oh
to be honest with you I've always said
as long as we are here we're here for a
reason and uh whatever that reason may
be
we're gonna figure it out
and we're gonna accomplish it and uh I'm
just waiting you know on
what it is
the reason why I'm still here and I
think for the most part the reason that
I'm still here is because
you know right now now I have a family
you know I have to look out for it and
take care of so
right now
everything is all about and uh
uh revolves around them
you know taking care of them and
teaching them that you know
life is not gonna be easy and nothing's
going to be given to you
like I say anything
that you're going to get out of life
you're going to have to work hard but
with that hard working dedication there
are some great rewards uh
to come from it yeah you were told you
were too big
from Mr Olympia no yeah yeah I did I was
told that one year but who told you that
one of the judges the judge said you
were doing one time I listened to a
judge and I'm like okay I'll never do
that again because the next year I came
in they said I was too small and I was
like okay I'm going to start taking my
own advice like I've always done and do
what I want to do
and that's when I came in
the heaviest ever at almost 300 pounds
on stage how are you too big to win
because isn't it like size of the muscle
proportion well yeah it's by shape in
Symmetry and condition
I guess I didn't have enough condition
at the size I was oh so like like less
body fat percentage water oh water yeah
I hear it's pretty crazy leading up to
24 hours before the judges
isn't it like you have to dehydrate a
certain time to show the muscle yeah
yeah how do you learn how to do that
you have to put your faith in God
for the most part because it's extremely
hard to do is extremely hard and you can
only do it for a certain amount of time
uh maybe the most you could probably do
that is probably like
three hours four hours at a time
maybe at the most but after that you uh
seriously putting the heart in danger of
collapsing
and that's happened
a lot lately what percentage of having
an elite uh bodybuilding physique is
lifting versus nutrition versus like
stretching versus like water intake like
if you were to make a pie what would the
slices look like with all of the
different equations that fall into
having an elite uh bodybuilding physique
sixty percent
is from the food
30 percent is from the workout
and the rest is everything else combined
in there sleeping and all that kind of
stuff yeah yeah because I used to think
you know if I'm in the gym working out
in
lifting as heavy as I possibly can with
doing a certain number of reps while I'm
doing it then I would get big I thought
that would be it but coming to find out
that size comes comes from eating and I
learned that the hard way when I had to
kind of like
stuff myself
and it was real hard
to do it first
and my body kind of adjusted and I got
used to it was there ever a period of
time where the eating and nutrition was
harder than the working out yeah it was
harder yeah yeah that that was the time
it was harder than working out when I
had to eat all that food like when I
went from 10 ounces to 12 ounces to 16
ounces
that's that's when it was harder than
working out and everything else how do
you how does your stomach expand so
quickly
it didn't expand quickly it took a long
time for me to do that it took probably
about two two or three months
for my stomach too I get to expand or
whatever to get used to that there comes
a certain point if I'm eating let's say
I go to like oh you can eat sushi in
Vegas like I'm going there and I always
end up in the middle of those yes I end
up ordering more than I can eat
obviously and I'm pushing myself because
I don't want to get charged for the
extra season I'm pushing myself to eat
the sushi and it's to a point where like
I'm like if I have another piece I'm
going to throw up and I don't know what
happens if I push through that wall
because I never have I usually try to
get someone else to eat it what is it
like like like do you ever like throw up
from eating so much food your body it
can always do it yeah you can always do
it yeah because I ain't gonna lie to you
when when I was in college they used to
have these all-you-can-eat places it was
like they hate it when you come in yeah
it was a dollar all you can eat pizza
and man I would eat so much it's a good
deal yeah you know and I'd be stuffed
and I'm like
I can eat some more because I'm gonna
you know all I gotta do is go in the
bathroom
and uh do some push-ups some sit-ups and
I can eat some more some sit-ups
on the floor of a bathroom
dirty I did that you did that I did that
to get in more pizza get in more pizza
just because you had to eat more for the
girls
worth
it's probably literally a dollars worth
what do you think about that was tough
what do you think about liver King's
diet of eating just like raw meat I I
still find that hard to believe you
don't believe that he eats only that uh
um no really
uh I I I I didn't think that was
possible
so what do you what is he missing in his
diet I don't know what he's missing I
don't know how he can do it you know I
know I could never do it
I don't think I could do it if my life
was on the line so he had a chef prepare
us meat and I asked I said how fresh is
this he says well this morning the meat
was alive and we're like doing a podcast
in the evening and that morning just
knowing that that animal was was living
this morning and now it's not just
tripped me out but yeah every bit of the
animal from the heart to the kidney
kidney testicles oh no I couldn't do it
it really wasn't that bad it kind of
tastes like sushi but a little bit worse
oh no it was salty the thought of would
make me kind of throw up
interesting it almost made me bone
marrow was really gross that one and
also the the kidneys because they felt
way you know everything's possible I
could do it none
no way yeah I I don't I I I I I'm still
shocked and amazed when I see that
well I've seen him do it like you know
I've seen him doing them many times and
I I still don't get it do you have any
advice for any young aspiring
bodybuilders or people that want to get
in shape maybe they don't quite have the
motivation that you do to get in the gym
consistently what do you recommend to
those people I mean there's no other way
to get in shape besides you know going
to the gym and eating uh a real healthy
diet but uh the best advice I give
somebody is what I've learned you know
that uh bodybuilding is all about
knowledge and the more you have the
better off you're going to be so I try
to tell somebody each and every
bodybuilder that comes up to me and
asked me
how do I become better and how do I get
to you know to where you are well and I
learned from experience you know
uh I didn't know anything at all about
bodybuilding when I got into it nothing
didn't know how to die posting nothing
but people taught me this stuff
so I just tell people to find somebody
who's very knowledgeable in who have
proved it you know they have proved it
you know
they have you know these certain
Champions that that you know they can
show you that they've given these people
these diets and and they've gone on and
become champions from what they've uh
taught them yeah find somebody like that
and and that's how you become a champion
what is the most amount of pain that
you've ever felt was it maybe like a
pinched nerve from a herniated disc was
it maybe a specific lift where you
pushed yourself extremely hard
or was it working like in the the cotton
thing picking out the the plants that
that wasn't pain that was probably
mental language yeah that was mental
language more than anything but pain man
that's kind of hard to say because I
remember when I broke my toe oh man that
was an awful did you drop a weight on
your toe stepped on a Lego You Dropped a
200 pound weight on your toes some uh
you got a lifting it did
and that was painful that was how does
it not crush your toe yeah exactly yeah
it would just be decimated you think but
it didn't you know it broke it and that
was about it
but that was a lot of pain to go through
I did that twice both of them how heavy
were the weights one was 25 pounds broke
it and I dropped it from the floor we
dropped 200 pound dumbbells right here
it wasn't from here yeah it was like the
25 pounds
but uh those were pretty painful that's
the the most pain you know I remember
when I herniated my discs
I mean
I it wasn't that painful and you know it
made a lot of noise
all right because I remember that but I
don't remember a lot of pain like when
they dropped that 200 pounds
don't bail on my tongue it was painful
it's hell and it hurt like hell both
times two of the most painful things
that I've gone through did you complete
the workout
both time no you did
the next day I went and uh did squats oh
my God oh
you did these squats leg pressing
everything yeah
yep sure did how do you how do you not
get sick like get a cold or like the flu
or like some high pain tolerance do you
do you feel sick but just go anywhere
like just push through it or do you just
not get sick
I've been sick two or three times in my
life I can recall that must have been
pretty bad though yeah yeah they were
pretty bad
one time was the time I moved into my
new house my first new house I remember
throwing up that time
and another time I was in the eighth
grade I remember throwing up that time
and those were only two times oh one
time I was on the airplane I threw up I
was only three times in my life I can't
remember throwing up yeah do you just
have like the perfect genetics it sounds
like a god-tier genetics like how are
your children do they not get sick no
they no no no no they get sick all the
time they get sick so that's your
one-off yeah yeah I I like phenomenon
that
it only happens to
every now and then I feel like someone
should study you from like the
discipline yeah the genetics themselves
yeah
oh my gosh so you've never like done
stem cells you've never tried to give
away stem cells or done like genetic
makeup research or something like that
not that I can recall right away I mean
we actually did do a genetic makeup on
Ronnie and he has been he came back on
the test as being under the one
percentile of genetic makeup so his body
will regenerate the the cells uh faster
than a normal person he doesn't get sore
after working out in the gym so it's
kind of like he's a one-off of the
population so it's kind of crazy but
that's why you are actually a anomaly
yeah something like that because he's a
phenomenal yeah yeah I think you were
really born to do bodybuilding yeah I
mean in every capacity yeah
yeah I was uh touched by God
be one of the greatest bodybuilders on
the planet and then I heard you're also
opening up another gym yeah yeah uh what
we're gonna do is uh we got all this
equipment from panata so we're gonna
open up our office gym to anybody in the
public that wants to come and work out
there cool
and uh
most certainly we're gonna
allow the Olympia competitors for us to
be a home gym for them to work out while
they're in town and where is that going
to be is that Texas Orlando Orlando yeah
well I guess you can call it Lake Mary
okay which is pretty close to Orlando
you have an idea when it's going to be
open we're trying to do it right before
the Olympia happened so over around
September somewhere October and we got
an invite to that right oh yeah yeah all
right we're in Orlando
it's free right what are you part of the
general public yeah all right okay go
for free then I'm in sounds good hey
thank you so much for coming on the ice
coffee hour this is honestly it was my
pleasure I had a farm you're so generous
with your time too which is very sweet
but time flies when you're having fun it
really does I really don't know it seems
like we've been doing this for like 30
minutes maybe I know but I think we've
been a little bit longer thank you so
much man this means the world to us that
you would come on it was my pleasure I'd
like to say I had a lot of fun doing
this cool oh if you can just look into
that camera and remind everyone to hit
the like button and subscribe everybody
out there remember hit the like button
and subscribe yeah buddy yeah buddy
lightweight lightweight
peanut thank you guys so much for
watching means a lot and uh until next
time perfect
thumbnail oh yeah sorry